[Musique]
quelles sont les possibilités
d'investissement en Afrique quelles sont
les secteurs porteurs quel est le profil
des investisseurs coûte des informations
financières bonjour boom toi junior
bonjour c'est pour tenter d'apporter une
réponse concrète à ces questions que
vous avez cofondé d'abord un acronyme
pour faire simple qui signifie
démocratiser l'accès aux affaires en
Afrique grâce à la technologie pour
commencer comment est né ce projet alors
le projet d'abat est né dans constat
simple c'est qu'il y a des opportunités
sur le continent mais les investisseurs
n'ont pas accès à l'information
nécessaire l'intelligence financière est
donc l'outil l'infrastructure qui leur
permet de déployer leur capitaux sur le
continent donc nous avons créé cette
plateforme pour permettre aux gens de
bénéficier de ces opportunités sur le
continent on va passer tout cela en
détail dans un instant le temps de
rappeler que d'abat c'est aussi en
Afrique un outil utilisé dans dans
l'agriculture dans certains pays
d'Afrique de l'Ouest il renvoie aussi à
la nourriture au fait de manger
exactement c'est ça ça veut dire en Ushi
ça veut dire manger et donc voilà c'est
un outil de pour la prospérité et nous
sommes dit que ce nom portait bien
l'image de ce que nous essayons de faire
vous êtes d'origine camerounaise
diplômée de l'université de Chicago
spécialiste en
développement de solutions financière
vous avez travaillé pour le Nasdaq si
j'ai bien compris et vous êtes rendu
compte que l'Afrique n'était pas
représentée ou quand elle était mal
représentée dans les bases de données
s'agissant des finances exactement donc
à Nasdaq je travaille sur les systèmes
qui donnaient de l'information aux
investisseurs instituts institutionnels
qui leur permettait de décider où placer
leur capitaux et on avait moins d'un
pour cent de notre base de données
couvrait le continent et de ce 1% là
seulement 90% couvrait l'Afrique
subsaharienne donc alors ça pose de ce
fait un problème parce qu'il n'y a pas
assez d'informations pour permettre aux
investisseurs de décider ou va falloir
capitaux quels sont donc vos solutions
alors nous ce que nous faisons c'est
dans un premier point nous rentrons en
partenariat avec les banques les fonds
les fonds de gestion sur le continent
accédant à leur information et nous les
mettons à disposition des investisseurs
sur notre application de ce fait
maintenant ils ont un portail simple qui
leur permet non seulement d'accéder à
l'information mais aussi à
l'intelligence financière pour prendre
la décision d'investir et de déployer
leur capitaux selon leur profil risque
et leur profils d'investisseurs de
quelle information parlons-nous alors
nous parlons sur les retours
d'investissement nous parlons des
secteurs porteurs nous parlons de
leur le potentiel retour sur sur leur
sur le capitaine le capital mis à
disposition alors et aussi nous parlons
de
de comment est-ce que ce
investissements peuvent impacter aussi
les différentes les différents pays dans
lesquels ils sont déployés boom toi
junior vous dites que avec daba vous
souhaitez contribuer à changer le
narratif sur l'Afrique on l'a déjà
entendu ça justement j'ai envie de vous
demander en quoi est-ce que votre
approche est originale pourquoi d'abord
et pas une autre structure alors le
narratif est de de être très souvent
négatif alors on parle de des
investissements de perte de fond alors
il y a des opportunités qui ont un fort
retour mais qui malheureusement n'ont
pas la peine non pas l'opportunité
d'être vu des investisseurs alors nous
ce que nous faisons c'est donc
d'apporter une lumière pour que les
investisseurs voient clair donc où
est-ce qu'ils peuvent mettre leur
capitaux à travers un portail simple
quels sont les garanties que vous donnez
à ceux qui vous feraient confiance
alors dans l'investissement il y a
toujours un risque mais nous ce que nous
faisons c'est que nous essayons de
filtrer les meilleures opportunités nous
rentrons en partenariat avec des fonds
d'investissement qui ont qui ont un
parcours d'investissement et qui ont
déjà prouvé leur retour sur le marché et
ce ne sont que ces investissements là
que nous mettons à disposition de nos
investisseurs sur la plateforme vous
êtes une fintech contraction de finances
et technologies ça fait un an que vous
existez dans l'investissement social
déjà quel est le bilan d'abat depuis que
vous êtes vous êtes là quels sont vos
réalisations les premiers enseignements
les premiers retours alors le bilan de
daba c'est nous sommes déjà aux
États-Unis une société de gestion de
patrimoine agrégé par la SEC nous avons
déjà facilité quelques investissements à
travers la plateforme et nous avons
actuellement 600 utilisateurs qui nous
utilisent et une liste d'attente de près
de 5000
[Musique]
alors on parle de gestion de patrimoine
on parle de portefeuille
quels sont de ce que vous avez identifié
les secteurs justement qui sont porteurs
pour ceux qui nous suivent là qui se
disent voilà cette affaire de daba
m'intéresse de quel secteur porteur
parlons-nous alors premièrement
l'application aujourd'hui est focalisée
sur les technologies donc tous les
toutes les compagnies qui sont tech ou
tech enable mais au-delà de cela il y a
les fintech il y a l'immobilier
l'assurance le commerce et la logistique
qui sont et l'éducation qui sont des
secteurs où nous voyons de forts
potentiels et qui dans les prochains
mois nous allons faire venir sur la
plateforme pour les rendre à disposition
de nos utilisateurs quels sont les
profils de vos utilisateurs aujourd'hui
60% de notre base d'utilisateurs se
trouvent aux États-Unis ce sont des
membres de la diaspora à peu près 30%
sont en Europe encore de la diaspora et
10% sur le sur le pays entre la tranche
d'âge entre 25 et 40 ans et donc voilà
nous cherchons à démocratiser à ajouter
plus de d'utilisateurs sur d'autres
plateformes avoir des profils un peu
plus variés on ne peut pas aborder ce
type de questions sans analyser
celle liée au climat des affaires en
Afrique sans faire évidemment de
généralités boom toi junior est-ce que
les administrations jouent le jeu on
pense au contraire qui peuvent être
d'ordre divers un juridique
administratif financière fiscale c'est
une très bonne question alors donc nous
ce que nous faisons c'est que nos
partenaires qui sont généralement des
banques on nous donne le le climat
juridique qui nous permet d'exercer sur
leur marché alors les administrations
elles ont tout à gagner de nous
permettre justement d'ouvrir leurs mains
quel jour le jour
actuellement nous sommes pas en contact
direct avec les administrateurs mais il
y a des conversations qui ont commencé
par contre mais on travaille avec des
organisations qui sont les banques qui
elles ont le contexte juridique
nécessaire et qui nous donne accès au
marché un mot rapide sur la place des
femmes dans ce que vous développez alors
essentiel très essentiel surtout nous
sachons très bien nous savons très bien
que les femmes représentent une forte
opportunité et après de 300 milliards de
d'ajout au PIB si les femmes sont
financées et ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous apportons des stratégies qui
sont dans lesquelles les femmes sont
membres d'un bord ou du management et
les investisseurs peuvent décider dit de
financer spécifiquement ce type de
compagnie merci